[MUSIC PLAYING]
WESLEY CHUN:
Greetings, developers.
And welcome to another episode
of the G Suite Dev Show.
I'm your host, Wesley Chun.
You may have heard about Google
Drive's Team Drives feature
recently.
There's plenty of excitement
around this product.
But beyond its hype
and the solutions
it brings, let's introduce
you to a writing Team Drive
applications using
the Google Drive API.
If you're really
new to Team Drives
and want to know
how to use them,
check out this guided tutorial.
Down below in the
video description,
you'll also find Team Drive
announcements as well as
an intro video.
So why Team Drives?
If you use G Suite
in your organization,
Google Drive is likely at
the center of your company
documents and collaboration.
However, Drive was
designed around users.
Users are owners of
files, users share
documents with other users,
users collaborate on documents,
and so on.
But this model
doesn't work as well
in larger organizations that
are more team-oriented rather
than user-centric.
Employees changing teams
or leaving the company
altogether may result
in files going missing.
Common solutions, like
assigning new owners of files,
using shared folders,
and even Google Groups,
isn't always successful as files
still appear to go missing.
Well, this is why
Team Drives were
created, to solve these core
problems for G Suite customers.
No more confusion and
mysteriously missing files.
Think of Team Drives as a
completely new type of drive
re-invented specifically
for teams and organizations.
While Team Drives work in
conjunction with regular Drive,
it's best to consider both as
separate parallel universes,
living side-by-side from
a user's perspective,
just like in the user
interface you see here.
That'll help avoid confusion.
While Team Drives
are relatively new,
we don't think you should have
to write completely new apps
just to leverage Team Drives.
The good news for those of you
already using the Drive API
is that you only need
to augment your code
to support Team
Drives and only when
you're ready to add Team
Drive functionality.
Yes, there's a new
collection of methods
plus additional arguments
to existing methods
for Team Drives.
But the net result is that all
of your existing applications
will continue to function
normally with regular Drive
So what are some of
the basic operations
that any Drive
developer should know
regardless of the type
of application you have?
Well, one, you should be
able to create a Team Drive.
Two, you should also know how
to add members to a Team Drive.
Three, you should
also be able to create
a folder in a Team Drive.
And four, you should be able
to import or upload files
to a Team Drive folder.
We'll look at more advanced
skills in upcoming videos,
but you've got to
start somewhere, right?
Before we walk through our
code sample that does all four
of these, make sure that you
have an applicable G Suite
domain, administrative access
to be able to manipulate
Team Drives in that domain.
Next, you should have the Google
APIs Client Library installed
in your development language.
We'll demo in Python
because, one, I know
a little something about it.
And two, it makes for great
pseudocode for everyone else.
Finally, you should
have a project
in the Developer's Console
with the Drive API enabled.
Once you're ready to go, let's
walk through this demo script
on the computer.
OK, on lines 1 through 14, we
have our boilerplate imports
and authorization code.
But there are a couple of lines
to look more carefully at.
In our application, we need a
universally unique identifier,
and we'll show you
where that comes in.
But we import that on line 2.
On line 8, we need the
full read/write scope
for Google Drive.
And on line 14, we create
the service endpoint
to the Drive API.
We're using Version 3 here.
Now let's look at our
first Team Drives function.
It's called Create Team
Drive, or create_td.
And it does exactly
what you think.
It creates a Team Drive
using the Create method
in the new Team
Drives collection.
Line 17 is where that
unique identifier comes in.
Think of a request_id
as a serial number
to ensure that apps
performing retries
don't create
duplicate Team Drives.
If you have heard the
term idempotent before,
this is exactly what
we're talking about.
UUIDs are unique, so that's
why we're using them here.
And most programming
languages, including Python,
have some sort of UUID library.
Note, this is the only way
to create a Team Drive.
So yes, creating a Team Drive
is different from creating
a folder in regular
Google Drive.
On lines 22 to 25, add_user
adds a member to a Team Drive
by calling
permissions.create, in a way
quite similar to sharing a
document with another user.
The supportsTeamDrives
flag on line 25
is obviously new and used when
calling existing Drive API
methods, but requesting
Team Drive functionality
On 27 to 30, create_td_folder
creates a folder
in a Team Drive
given the Team Drive
ID, which we got from the
return value of create_td.
So create_td_folder takes that
Team Drive ID and a folder
name.
All files and
folders can only live
in one place on
Team Drives, meaning
they can only have one parent.
This is nearly
identical to the code
to create a folder
in regular Drive
except for the
supportsTeamDrives flag
and a single parent.
I'll let you guess what
import_csv_to_td_folder
does on lines 32 to 35.
Like create_folder,
this code imports a file
with files.create, just
like for regular Drive,
but has a supportsTeamDrives
flag again.
And those are the
four main functions.
The rest of the code is
just the supporting cast.
Lines 37 to 39 are just
various definitions.
On 37, we have the MIME type
of a Google Drive folder.
And on 39, we have the MIME
type for Google Sheets files.
Sandwiched in between
is the CSV file
that we're going to import.
And by import, we mean
upload and convert
to Google Sheets format.
On disk, we have the file stored
with the CSV file extension.
So we have to add that here
in the media body on line 34.
But as a Google Sheet, we no
longer need that CSV extension.
So we just take the name as is.
And you can see that
as a second parameter
to the function call,
which gets assigned
into the files metadata on 33.
By the way, if you
really want to run this,
you're going to have to
import your own CSV file, so
change the name if necessary.
Now, you could change this
code to upload the raw CSV
and not convert to Sheets.
And the way you would do that
is, instead of using the Google
Sheets MIME type, you would
just use text/csv, which
is the MIME type for CSV files.
And 41 to 48, just run all of
these functions one at a time,
then displaying to the user
that the function completed.
So on line 41, we call create_td
to create a Team Drive called
Corporate shared TD.
And we save the return value,
which is the Team Drive ID.
On line 43, we call add_user,
pass in the Team Drive ID,
and the name of the
user we want to add.
As before, if you want
to really add a user,
change this email
address to a real one
for a user in your domain.
On 45, we take the Team Drive
ID and call create_td_folder,
creating a folder called
Manufacturing data in my Team
Drive.
And then on 47, we call
import_csv_to_td_folder, pass
in the folder_id of the
file that we just created--
Manufacturing data-- the
source file-- inventory,
or inventory.csv--
and the Sheets MIME
type for conversion.
Again, if you don't
want to convert,
then just use text/csv here.
And that's it.
So that's how you can
test drive Team Drives
in less than 50 lines of code.
You can read more in the
code deep dive blog post
and run it with Python 2 or 3.
It works with both.
But no matter which
version you use,
you should expect the
output from the print
calls in the script plus a
new Team Drive folder called
Corporate shared TD,
inside of which you'll find
a Manufacturing data folder.
And inside of that should be
your Inventory Sheets file,
imported successfully from CSV.
To get started, check
out this page in the Docs
that introduces Team Drives,
concepts, some of the rules,
and basically how
Team Drives work.
Once you're ready to
take your first steps,
check out this Docs page,
enabling Team Drive support,
and specific differences in
using the API when writing apps
for regular Google Drive
versus Team Drives.
Finally, see the complete
video from Google Cloud Next
2017, where you'll learn about
Team Drives for developers
and hear directly from
partners who have already
implemented Team Drive apps.
So that's our tour of Team
Drive basics for developers.
Keep an eye out for more Team
Drives episodes coming soon.
Thanks for joining
us today, and please
subscribe to our channel.
This is Wesley Chun, and
we'll see you upstairs
in the G Suite.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hey, everyone.
Thanks for watching.
Check out these related videos.
And we'll see you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]